SECRETARY, WE DO APPRECIATE YOU
THANK WI U
>>> WE DO HAVE SOME
NEWSOR YOUIF YOU LOOK MAP, IT I
CLEAR REE RUSSIANS
HA SOMS IS IN THE H,CIRI
CERN NOW FORLARGES IN UKRAINRE
THERE, SEEING WHAT REALLY LOOKS
ep JACT OF DEFNCE, NICK.PL ON.
WHAT YOU GOT BEHBASICALLY A .
THIS IOD A PDAY DESTINATIO LL A
HAPPENING HERE.DINARY CHAINSSIN
WHING.
YOU CAN SEE WHERE THISESE BA TH
IT
IN PILES, ANTHEN ORDARYOUNG PEOE
20SHOVELS, FILLING U
E SANDBAGS
TRYING TO COME HERE THROUGH THE
LEFT HERE WITH EMPTY
CENTER. THE P IE
OWY FORMART
THEY MIGHT S A RUSSIPHIBIOUS LAE
THAT IN SOME PEOPLE HERE IN
THE BIKINIS, WE SAW SOMEBODY
YER A DIP, THIS
CO OY DESTINATN
MIGHT SEE RUSSIAN AMPHIBIOUS
ABOUT ANO COAST OF HERE THAT W S
UKINIA
RUSSIAN SHELLING KIND OF
CIVILIAN SHIELD  ALLOW
BU OF FEELING APPROACH TOA
OF A CITY UNITED WHEN YOU SEE
TAKES POINT. GET TRUCKS TOBAGS,
THE CITY
PARTS OF THE
CENT ITH IT IS
PICTURE  FORTIFICATIONS OF THED
ODESA I, YING TO THEMSELVES TH
HE SAME THING
NOW.
ONE MAN TOLD ME HE WEPT WHEN HE
SAID
THE SOVIETS FOUGHT OFFHES THE KT
IRONY, IT ISAR
HERE BETWEEN PEOPLE WHO AR
SE THIS SO
IMIR
THIS INVASION OF UKRNE,
CONTRAE FE
HAVENG AONY
AGAIN.
ONINN
EARLIER ON, JOHN.
THEY'RLKT  MOVED INTO THE TOWN O
KHLIANS, THEY'RE NOWING
HUMARITRUCKS,
PARKED UP ENTRAL
BIG WHITE TRUCKS, THAR
MAY BE ABOUT TO HAND OUT
AND LOCAL OFFICIALS THERE HAVE
EN THIS MOVILLY E .
JOHN.
IN OTHER PLACES WHERE RUSSVE ES
T IN
2014, 2015, THEY SENDN
GI W FAKE SUPPORT FOR TH
BE SEEING THAITR
THE CENTRAL SQUARE NOW
TH WL OFFIAL
WARN. SYNTHESIZED
R SUORTHE RUSSIAF KHERSON.
CONTRAST THAT 'R
AND THAT'S OF LOCALS BEING
WALKED AWAY, L M
WALKED AD
DISAPPEARING, LOOTL AT RUS
EANS F
LIFE.HN?
>> WE'RE WATCHING A HUMAN N
HERE, VI SAND FROM T
FROM THIS RE AREA IN ODESA
Y NTO WHE EXPECTING TO BE TH
STORICITE THIRD MOST POPULINE.
MEN, MEN AGES, TEENARS THEIR 30
LINES OF THIS
FIGHT L DA Repor
THEM
OUR COUNTRY, FOR SURE.
orter: THERE'S YOUR